hi guys
today i'm playing another minisode of to
the moon for you i played the first
minisode if you missed that
go and click somewhere around here maybe
here click here yes click here to see
the first minisode and then come back
and watch this one because apparently
this one has a lot more to do with the
actual story of to the moon so i'm very
excited to play it it's by free bread
games again just like everything else
yeah let's play this wow elise is
starting to leave
oh yeah so in the last episode it
finished with or episode minisone it
finished with you're then chucking the
tomatoes at the windows we're obviously
starting from where we left off which is
pretty cool
i guess we'll save the cleanup for after
the break
we've altered we've alter
get that external fruit collector set up
we've also what what is that what kind
of language is this
perfectly cool in the snow and kept
fresh too
uh get this it's like we're inside and
the fridge is outside
mind blown
precisely
sure good job
i knew it
i wonder if the others are leaving early
now the road's cleared
okay so they're going now
eh might as well i can't believe the
calls pushed our christmas party this
late
oh no not a late christmas party are you
heading home ready too
yeah why not
no she's not very happy is she
i'm spending the eve my sister's family
they don't live far from here
with a little brat her i love how he
just comes out with these things ah what
i missed you
yeah well that little brat still got me
a better gift than yours
oh
bad friend
hey at least i tried to get my partner
something something for my partner
and like a certain somebody
guess again
oh
she was saving it
what is that
it's an ambient sound maker
it cycles through soothing background so
it sounds like beaches or a chorus of
crickets
why would watts want that
check this out
we're in the sea
it sounds like something i could do on
my phone
very true
oh yeah well this also allows for
recording a custom track of your own to
loop back
just press rec
and you can make your own custom
ambience custom ambient sound to work
too what is wrong with my voice today i
can't i can't speak apparently
again phone i was thinking that i didn't
want to say it ah
i guess neither of us are particularly
good gift givers
hey i'll still take it
i'll probably record rob getting scolded
to the custom track and fall asleep to
it or whatnot
yeah yeah
anyway
how about you
you got plans
wow
oh ho
come here you stud
what
what
wait i probably said that in the wrong
voice it's probably supposed to be a
sexy voice
oh
is it wine or have you been getting
handsomer by the day
my dear i am sober to brick and you are
still steamy like a hot bun
when i looked into your eyes just then
it's as if i'm hearing the gentle waves
of the ocean well you are my friend
oh my god he just slapped his bum are
you naughty little nixon what are we
playing
if not for my back i'd just pick you up
and
awkward
hey
hey
oh my gosh can you imagine
oh no way it's snowing outside
yeah it is and the crickets are playing
now
awkward
oh my gosh
okay i think that's enough for today
yeah
definitely i'm heading out you do that
oh
let's go outside
hopefully we don't run into those old
canoodling people again
because that was a bit strange
hello
who is this
hello
mmm
interesting
what do you want to do shall we
you want to go out
looks like mickey mouse's hand doesn't
it
who in there all right
the feet
go to
do we go
to
the lounge
back to the christmas party see if
everyone's left
i remember that party it was quite fun
actually
oh look oh no there are some people left
i'm so relieved that we're finally
getting a break it'd be nice to spend
some time with the family
have a good evening lisa you deserve it
everyone does especially willis and
timer
to be honest i'm worried about them yeah
they do work way too hard for their age
honestly i don't think i'd be able to do
theirs when the time comes
what oh
oh that's morbid
no man
i know herman cops got our night covered
by contracts and all but i still feel
kind of uneasy
they're our competitor after all
yeah but i guess that's one of the few
ways to get some reliable time off in
this job
besides we'll be doing the same thing
for them so they better do a good job
i'm lost i don't know what they're
talking about
anyway i think you want to go don't you
am i okay
let's
go
let's go to
the lobby
because you want to go see your family
oh hello
eva uh about earlier no it's okay you
don't need to
no less you don't understand
you see sometimes when a man loves the
woman very much
oh shush you
ah awkward
yep
come on then
my stuff's back at the office oh bloody
hell fine
i went everywhere else first oh well
hey eva
hey eddie how's
oh no door
oops not bad you can just press the
button again oh well nobody exactly
oh you weird kid
okay
oh hello
you're right roxy
oh hi ava
yep i'm just waiting on rob he's riding
under maintenance so we're
carpooling hey rob you're ready
just a minute
anyway what's up to
uh not much just telling him to have
dinner with my sister's family
we've always had our christmas dinner
together and they've been waiting
wow how nice of them the tacky surely
wouldn't have stuck around if it been me
i bet
is she calling you fat
mean you got any plans tonight well i
gotta meet up with some folks later
folks
but first i got a date with a good old
couch and some ice cream that sounds
like a perfect date
i'm gonna grab a whole bucket and scoop
it and then i'm gonna spoon it
sounds like a lovely time
yup yup
yes it does
it definitely does
okay let's grab your stuff
dear diary today i shoot not again
the door was open too better look at
waveguide oh yeah cause
when we played last time
um what's his face read her diary
i remember that
she said keep better care of it
might get your bag
and go
shoot
right
oh oh oh
is that rob
i just got ready but now dr winters
forgot her stuff
you ready ed almost
how's the situation outside looking
all cleared up probably because the cold
good it's about time
why were they so angry again
can't remember oh well i'm sure i'll
find out
go to the lobby
now we can go
heading off
you're still here
yep
and i'm staying here tonight
wait what everyone's heading home
what can i say it's just kind of
hard-working samaritan that i am
can we do
she can't wait to get to her ice cream
neil bob
it's robert
rob
what
anyway
have a good evening your sister's place
well i love this weird random stuff okay
you're really gonna just stay here on
the only break we've gotten in months
yup
all this mansion to myself yes please
all right then
she's not gonna go she's gonna stay
hey if you want
hmm
never mind
oh she wanted to stay with him
look at her little car
eva
hey sis i'm heading over now
see you in a bit
ugh imagine how freaky that would be
that whole office to yourself
i'd hire a massive ball pit
it's not fun on your own though
you rock you rule
anyway
oh
and yep
there he is
he's staying there all by himself
but isn't this like christmas for you
guys
yeah well
i don't know what he's up to
hon you should invite him over to dinner
what don't be observed
you're thinking too much into it silly
i don't mean for anything else just for
coworkers sake you know
i know the guy
he's not one to come over
anyways get the dishes started for you
i'll be there in just a bit
okay han i'll see you then
no you can't go
eva what was that
you okay hon
what was that are you there eva
it's herself
what
eva can you hear me
yeah
i'll be there in just a bit
okay hon see you then
what
that was weird
and confusing
hmm
come on 30th time's the charm
so he's trying to make the dream thing
that we saw in actual to the moon
and the moment of truth
circuit abnormality detected main power
disconnected
how does that even
i'd better get down to the basement and
reset the switch before someone sees
ah creepy dark places at least the
elevator's an auxiliary power i could
reach the basement from the lobby
oh creepy
go to the lobby
and then the basement
oh
that's a pretty cool way to get down to
the basement
it's expecting to see a door but no
a moving platform
okay
for a tech facility the power supply
sure is unreliable
access profile loaded dr new watts
access time 1947.
or 10 to 8.
all right let's get you booted up first
power status charging for reignition
and now let's see what happened here
it's almost as if someone did a manual
shut off
fetching operation record
i don't understand
this can't be right
there must be a glitch in the system
why what happened
who's there
yeah
defend yourself with a broom
okay
what the hell
so i've got the most badass weapon in
the whole entire world
nothing can stop me now
footsteps
who
it's gonna be evil though isn't it but
the door was locked okay that's weird
but she probably has key
i'm gonna hit eva with a broom she's
gonna hate me
ah
there you
are power restored
how's the towel hon
that helps thanks
what's wrong with you ain't nobody gonna
whack my sister like that
sheesh it was an accident all right
your face was an accident
best comeback ever
you just go around the office swimming
and swinging a broom around all day
look i was in beast mode and she just
suddenly appeared on my turf
it's not my fault i was born with such
crazily vast reflexes
why did you guys come over anyway
you're one to ask staying all alone in
the office on your holiday off who does
that
it was her idea
darling right it is i ain't having no
part of my sister sub by himself on on a
night like this
i wasn't so
you just shut up and listen i really
like her she's cool
eva called in some old friends and we're
all gonna have a nice dinner together
and you're gonna enjoy every moment of
it
wow you kind of remind me of someone
that i know
who who evo
hey kitty can i open the box dad can i
go and ask eva
and ask what go ask an evil it's not
ours
hey kid
dude what's in the box
what's in the box
uh we don't actually know what
yeah come to think of it those exact
same boxes were here last year too
well can we open them
no i don't think i don't know whose they
are
so they just sit here yep
that's what they do
i don't get it
me neither
all right
and now what
they're there hun
it's actually not that bad
what was that
why is he still here
where am i supposed to go i'm not
supposed to i can't go anywhere you came
to talk to me
hey sorry about your face don't talk to
me
it was a soft end of the broom sheesh
come to think of it i should have been
charging you for facial massage
go away
fine
can i talk to the guy
man neil we've only just got here and
you've already got tracy all worked up
workplace hazard can't help it
yeah it's a dangerous place don't even
want to imagine what you do with the mop
our insurance policy forbids me from
handling one
so they like decorations
i don't know man i don't know
okay so it looks like i need to go
elsewhere
are you going to
oh
hello
oh hiya
i thought you went home with your ice
cream yeah i thought so too
but i was as i was happily pigging out
on the couch eva called and asked for a
pickup what but she's already here
hello
what the
hi uncle neal
the last time you two came by you called
me a poopoo face that was tommy he's
mean
wow that kid's growing up to be a lizard
uh sorry lily
it's been a while neil
yep
eva just dragged you guys right out of
your loving home huh
oh it's nice to come and visit the kids
were getting bored at home anyway
wow wow what let's go inside we could be
missing dinner by now oh yes i should go
say hi
okay so now i'm going back in
yeah that's what i thought
escaping
too many people too much socialization
if that's even a word
look she's holding the dark thing it's
not a duck what is it beaver what is
that a beaver it's a plaid flat oh it's
a platypus the platypus
it's not mine but ma said it's i'm i'm
it's care taken out
i protect it from all evil
can i see it
are you evil
not really
hmm okay you can applaud five minutes
hey are you a real doctor
what do you mean
like do you do surgeries and stuff
no
then you're not a real doctor
do you listen to dr dre
no
me neither but neil says dre's not a
real doctor and he still got my respect
so back off
she just talks to oh funny
kid's like oh
what do i say to that
hey jamie what are you doing with that
stuffed animal don't waste out on me son
hey
should i stand it's just plait plat
yeah dad chillhacks
guys can play with stuffed animals too
feeling all better i'll live
you know either hon you gotta come over
more i rarely see you anymore
well winter tends to be our busiest
season hopefully we'll get more of a
break soon don't work too hard now
you know what i'm always here if you
need me
that's
nice
why do you have to go all the way around
just to talk to her okay fine
hey thanks for helping me drive liddy
and the kids over
no biggie as long as you hold up your
side of the deal what was the side
yeah i got it
i'm serious two buckets of ice cream no
cheap outs oh okay
ben jerry's yes
yeah roxy i will like we're talking
jumbo size here we're the capital
and when i say buckets i mean buckets
as in i want to use them as recycling
bins when i'm done with them
yeah
where do you shop
thanks for having us over eva
hey i just hope i wasn't interrupting
anything not at all it's nice to take
those two rascals out
johnny's house has a beautiful view but
it's a bit remote for the kids to come
camp out
they do get to play outside nicely but i
keep fearing they'd trip and fall down
the cliff
that would be bad
no
that would be
super
sub optimal
that's the one suboptimal okay
jingle bells batman spells
hey has anyone seen neil
we ran into him in the hall but he
didn't follow us back in
seems like he went back down for some
reason
let's check it out
wait so he went back down here
did he i thought he went back to the
office obviously no
why is he outside what's he doing
hello
who's calling
who is this
son
son he has a son is that you neil
oh right it's his dad
why aren't you talking to them
was it something that did
no it's not them
then why why did you why did you come
back
i told you already it was my sister's
idea
you could have stopped her
what
look thanks for coming back and bringing
the folks and all
but just
don't do something like that again
do what
where are you going
home i've got things to work on
what the hell is wrong with you
good call eva
i don't know what's going on there but
for pineapple's sake loosen up
these people came all the way out here
to spend the evening with you
when was the last time you even had
dinner with other people
my sister brought her family to keep you
company even lily and the kids came
you still remember them right you even
made that stupid game based on that case
what are you gonna do when you go home
you'll eat a frozen pizza by yourself
just give yourself a break for tonight
sheesh
anyway
i'm not going to just stand out here in
the code tossing words at you
you do what you want i'm heading inside
just know there's a chair upstairs for
you whether you're coming or not
you go either
i'll turn around watts
the doors
oh
that was short
ah look at them they're all eating
dinner it makes me want to want to have
christmas again
you've got to wait so long for christmas
now it's just been christmas
she's like oh my gosh what's happening
get the platypus
what are you recording
laughter happiness
where freebird games community
a message
oh
yes seriously read this
and help out
i've already done it
but yeah so the
the art worker is in hospital
oh which is a shame
hopefully it gets better soon
well
well what
that wasn't so bad was it
everybody had a good time
yeah i guess so
hey can you guys give me a lift milford
world stuff
she was dreaming
where is she
hey can you guys give me a lift neil
says he needs the company car tonight
i'm confused
that actually gave me shivers
what sure han let's get you home wait
what
that's not fair
that's not fair at all
no
so she was dreaming and that was back in
her past
but she
and that would explain why she saw
herself standing in front of her car
oh it's all so intense that was really
good as normal it was very short maybe i
missed some stuff
but it was cute and lovely just like
every other free brad game and
now he's going back on to the second
episode so he's gonna make his longer
game
and that was the one that you saw at the
end of a brad story
so
i'm very excited for that anyway give
this video a thumbs up if you enjoyed i
really appreciate it and have a lovely
day or evening bye
fetch it
good bird
no no you gotta give it back
no
stupid bird